What are the ingredients and
for an industrial revolution,
new energy sources at a dash of cutting
edge communications technology and top
it all off with an emerging
mode of transportation.
When our society goes through
an industrial revolution,
we spur economic growth and completely
changed the world we live in.
We've seen the effects of two already.
So how would things
change if we had a third?
This is what f and here's what would
happen if there was a third industrial
revolution.
According to economist Jeremy Rifkin,
we're already on the cusp of
a third industrial revolution,
a convergence of the internet,
renewable energy,
and automated transportation.
If we embrace this transformation,
it could decentralize nearly every
industry on earth giving more power to the
people. How would this be an important
weapon against climate change?
How long can a civilization exist
surviving on a finite resource like fossil
fuels? Well, we might find
out sooner than we'd like.
According to Rifkin,
our current economic system and our
planet will eventually expire if we don't
move away from a carbon based
world. So how do we do that? Well,
it's already started and it was all
triggered by our embrace of the worldwide
web before the Internet.
The costs to spread your knowledge
and information was pretty expensive.
For example, let's say you wanted to
share your ideas through a newspaper.
Not only would you have to worry about
the initial cost of setting up shop,
but you'd also have to spend
money on every single copy
you made and distributed.
Nowadays after the initial
cost of accessing the internet,
you can produce unlimited copies of your
ideas and get them out to millions of
people without any further spending.
This phenomenon is known as zero marginal
cost and it could be the foundation of
the third industrial
revolution with the Internet.
Hundreds of millions of people are
producing and sharing music videos,
news blogs and ebooks essentially for
free bypassing the capitalist market
altogether.
We don't have to rely on a couple of
giant corporations to feed us all our
information and now that phenomenon is
expanding from the virtual world to the
physical world of goods and services.
For instance,
let's say you and a bunch of neighbors
want to start your own power grid based
on renewable energy.
Well,
with today's technology you can do that
and then you could even use that grid to
power driverless cars to run
a local ride share program.
You'd be creating a sustainable economic
system that would essentially cost you
nothing after the initial setup.
If Society embraces the
possibilities of using the internet,
renewable energy and automatic
transportation together,
it could restructure our economy.
Traditional corporations
would be disrupted and the
power would be returned to
the local communities,
will also be able to collect a lot more
information about the world around us,
allowing our economy to
operate at top efficiency.
As we continue to play sensors
on just about everything,
we'll be able to track things like
the flows of natural resources,
traffic and shipments.
All this available data will allow us
to increase productivity and decrease
waste and our ecological
footprints dramatically.
So maybe our future's
not so bleak after all,
or maybe all this global con activity.
We'll just open us up to a
whole new type of threat,
but that's a topic for another.
What if.